Kenny s has sadly retired from
professional Counter-Strike I loved
every second moment
and for those who
didn't catch all of his magical plays
you might be wondering how good was
Kenny s well even when he started his
career in CS Source Kenny was an
absolute demon with the awe after making
the switch to CS go Kenny jump between
several different now iconic French Orcs
pulling off some truly mind-boggling
plays along the way
oh that is bad
impression up close he needs shocks to
support him he's about to reflect but
what
oh my God Kenny but after he won a major
in 2015 valve gutted his beloved off and
things were never quite the same but
with over 700 000 internment winnings
and a laundry list of highlights Kenny
might just be remembered as the greatest
Opera of all time but Kenny yet stuck in
this site finding more that's brilliant
up close oh my goodness Kenny s